[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au centre des
arts et des loisirs de buchelay pour le
mini-festival la balle à diverses voici
le sommaire huit spectacles différents à
destination des enfants le mini-festival
la balade hiver se produira dans divers
lieux culturels en vallée de seine cet
événement est organisé par l'association
les 400 coups nous avons assisté à l'une
des représentations directrice musicale
de la maîtrise de trappes et gabriela
bouda a reçu les insignes de chevalier
de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur elle a été décorée notamment
pour son investissement dans
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique de saint quentin en yvelines
nous revenons sur son parcours et enfin
le musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines présente sa nouvelle exposition
sur la couleur orange dans les années
1960-1970 couleur phare dans le design
l'art ou encore la vie quotidienne
[Musique]
je me trouve dans le centre des arts et
loisirs de buch les six va se jouer deux
spectacles de la balade divers mi
festival ce sont en tout huit spectacles
complètement différent à destination des
enfants pendant les vacances scolaires
dans toute la vallée de seine cet
événement est organisé par l'association
les 400 coups eux de labrusse bonjour
bonjour vous êtes donc le président de
l'association du rupture directeur
directeur de l'association du 15 au 28
mars à vous proposez donc une
programmation de spectacles vivants quel
est l'objectif pour votre association
c'est de favoriser dans la vallée de la
seine le développement du spectacle
payant pour les jeunes publics et les
familles notamment en travaillant avec
des lieux de petites communes de
de donner un endroit où le spectacle ne
va pas nécessairement beaucoup donc
pouvoir proposer aux enfants et à leurs
familles des spectacles de proximité
d'une certaine façon pour éviter les
grands déplacements il ya beaucoup dans
cette partie du territoire il ya
beaucoup de
communes rurales ou périurbaines qui
n'ont pas réellement de programmation à
l'année donc c'est une façon d'être
présents sur le territoire pour pour
favoriser le spectacle jeune public dont
on sait l'importance
de pour les enfants d'être confronté à
de la chair du vivant à des spectacles
vivants après deux années devant des
écrans alors je les dis 1,8 hectare de
forme complètement variés oui c'est
l'intérêt du spectacle jeune public
c'est que les traits pluridisciplinaire
donc il y aura du théâtre du conte de la
danse de la musique un petit peu toutes
les formes possibles de 2 deux
propositions de création d'aujourd'hui
dans le domaine du jeune public vous le
disais dans différents lieux yvelinois
dans la vallée de seine met donc ses
spectacles vont être aussi joué dans
différents lieux culturels
nous n'avons pas de lieu à notre propre
disposition mais donc on travaille en
partenariat avec différentes communes et
aussi des structures culturelles des
théâtres donc le par exemple y aura des
des étapes au théâtre simone signoret de
conflans sainte honorine qui était un
très gros un très gros lieux et parfois
on est on est dans des salles
polyvalentes comme ici au centre des
loisirs de muscler ses c'est tout le
reste on travaille aussi avec des
grosses communes avec les mureaux par
exemple qui est un joli partenariat avec
montjeu la jolie falla c'est très varié
mais aussi donc des petites villes
j'étais que si j'ai des biotech très
bien lors d'un de ses spectacles
s'appelle les petites maisons dans la
forêt en contes pour enfants est mise en
scène par nathalie les regarder
il est
[Musique]
des comptines que l'on connaît tous dans
le spectacle musical les petites maisons
dans la forêt les personnages des contes
traditionnels sont placés dans une forêt
imaginaire magique la particularité
c'est que j'ai pris des chansons
traditionnelles que les enfants
connaissent mais qui sont remises en
situation et du coup elle s'intègre tout
naturellement dans le récit ce spectacle
pour les 3-6 ans et jouer au centre des
arts et de loisirs de buchelay dans le
cadre du mini festival la balade d'hiver
organisé par l'association les 400 coups
les enfants ont participé pendant 40
minutes à sept représentations
interactives il ya une telle est étroit
apprendre en particulier
warsh c'est intéressant et par votre
reprendre les chansons qu'elle connaisse
qu'elle connaisse et c'était pas mal
je trouve que ces petites histoires pour
les enfants ces histoires très simples
sont des clés de compréhension de la
nature des lois de la nature et quelque
chose d'aussi simple que le petit vieux
ans est la petite vieille en sucre ça
déploient beaucoup de choses sur la
difficulté de communiquer les disputes
nathalie l'yonne qui a créé ce spectacle
il ya dix ans comme bien continuer à
jouer ses représentations prochainement
dans les yvelines de labrusse temps on
vient de voir le reportage les 400 coups
c'est finalement une jeune association a
créé en 2019 les balades de saison sont
un peu votre marque de fabrique
oui l'association a été créée pour
pallier la disparition d'un gros
festival que nous organisions avant qui
s'appelait les francos qui pendant
pendant trois semaines proposé de la
même façon de très nombreux spectacles
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'était
devenu un peu trop lourd pour nous on a
un peu implosé en vol donc on s'est
restructurée pour proposer un nouveau
projet qui permet de décliner justement
de cette forme de festival mais en trois
temps qui est à 3,33 temps forts
beaucoup plus léger plus simple à
organiser et bah oui c'est tout neuf
c'est tout neuf en plus ça a démarré ça
devait démarrer ses ballades de saison
en 2020 eh ben ça n'a pas eu lieu en
2021 ça a été très compliqué donc là on
prend un peu notre notre rythme de
croisière on espère cette année cette
saison 2021 2022 et quand rigide balade
de saison corps clé
les spectateurs comprennent bien des
spectateurs
c'est du coup finalement maladie vert
était au thème c'est exactement ici une
quinzaine de jours fin novembre début
décembre pour l'automne une quinzaine de
jours on février en gros pot pour les
balades hiver avec la particularité de
travailler sur le temps des vacances
scolaires comme ça va être là et puis
une selle de celles de printemps
printemps été qui a lieu fin mai début
juin parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
aussi que souvent les salles de
spectacles notamment ferment leur lieu à
cette époque là il ya plus de
programmation alors que c'est un moment
où les familles les écoles aurez
peut-être envie de voir des spectacles
on arrive vers la fin de l'année donc on
a essayé de rentrer dans ce créneau
aussi pour va pour proposer des choses
quand il n'y a plus grand chose de ce
qui se passe et pourquoi s'intéresser
particulièrement aux jeunes publics
ouais c'est un peu notre notre adn puis
parce que parce que comme j'expliquais
on a repris d'une certaine façon les
missions du festival des francos et on
travaille
depuis toujours sur sur sur ce créneau
là parce que parce que c'est passionnant
parce que comme j'expliquais tout à
l'heure il ya beaucoup de propositions
très varié très très audacieuse qui sont
proposés par les compagnies c'est très
souple c'est très libre le jeune public
beaucoup plus que dans les têtes le
spectacle pour adultes qui est parfois
formaté là il ya beaucoup de choses très
variées très très étonnante qui se passe
c'est oui à une grande liberté qui est
assez chouette l'éducation il va merci
beaucoup d'avoir été votre invité merci
gabriel avoda raisner et la directrice
musicale de la maîtrise de trappes et
chef de choeur au conservatoire de
suresnes elle vient de recevoir les
insignes de chevalier de l'ordre
national de la légion d'honneur pour son
investissement dans l'association pour
la musique à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2010 je regardais son portrait
voilà ministère de la culture la gratte
chevalier légion d'honneur gabriel la
boda 40 ans de service à le choc
mercredi 16 février gabriela bodha a été
fait chevalier de l'ordre de la légion
d'honneur au conservatoire de musique et
de danse de trappes grande chef de
choeur international elle a été
récompensé pour son investissement pour
l'association de la promotion de la
musique de saint quentin en yvelines
d'origine hongroise ce sont ses parents
qui l'ont fait aimer la musique dès son
plus jeune âge on chantait dans l'église
avec ma mère on jouait du jazz
parallèlement à l'école navale et cours
de musique elle se forme avec les plus
grands chefs de choeur et sort diplômé
du conservatoire national de dépôt cren
elle poursuit ensuite sa carrière en
partant maroc en chine en inde où elle
travaille avec tous les publics jeunes
adultes amateurs professionnels elle
revient finalement en france et devient
2015 la nouvelle chef de choeur de la
pléiade de trappes la légion d'honneur
représente donc une consécration je suis
super heureuse je suis très émue très
touché par cette distinction c'est la
reconnaissance de la france 2
pas de seulement de mon travail parce
que ce que je fais c'est toujours la
réussite d'une équipe les enfants et le
président de l'association pour la
promotion de la musique de saint quentin
en yvelines sont tous très fiers de
cette distinction
gabriella
formidable là elle a fait un travail
absolument énorme et puis ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est que c'est un travail de
terrain j'ai été très contente pour elle
et c'est pas du coup j'étais contente
d'avoir une prof comme ça dans la cage
bauchi c'est une professeur en direct
c'est la paire professeur d'être happé
coeur dirait il va avoir une médaille de
du président macron ses deux fils marwan
al anis étaient aussi présents ils ont
démontré à leur manière que la musique
chez les bouddhas est une véritable
histoire de famille
[Musique]
toujours à saint quentin en yvelines le
musée de la ville présente orange la
couleur des années peuple jusqu'au 2
juillet cette exposition part à la
recherche des traces du orange dans le
design l'art ou encore la vie
quotidienne
voici le souk hôtel en 1963 dans une
couleur beige kaki et de voici dans les
années soixante dix orange ce téléphone
est symptomatique d'une époque celle des
années 60-70 que l'on appelle les années
pop en engouement particulier pour cette
couleur vive dans tous les domaines du
quotidien elle est mise à l'honneur dans
une exposition au musée de la villa
saint quentin en yvelines
moulin à café celui qui est présenté en
blanc date de 1956 est l'un des premiers
moulins à café motorisée de chez
moulinex et
la fin des années 60 début d incendie le
même moulin à café sera colorée en
orange pour s'adapter à la fois aux
goûts du public des nombreuses marques
et décline donc l'art objets en orange
diverses explications permettent de
comprendre le groupe pour cette couleur
évidemment un phénomène culturel qui est
d'autant plus remarquable qu'il apparaît
à peu près partout dans le monde enfin
du moins dans l'hémisphère nord ben est
sans doute parce que cette couleur
orange avait plusieurs plusieurs vertus
bon d'une part elle était relativement
inédite c'était également une couleur
qui
qui avait quelque chose de relativement
dynamique
joyeux extrêmement voyante l'oranje se
développe aussi dans le domaine de la
sécurité elle apparaîtra même si on
l'était j'étais dans les années 80 le
goût pour le range commence à se
terminer mais le tgv forcément été conçu
plusieurs années auparavant et le range
tgv a été validée dès 1977 on était là
au coeur de la période où on cherchait à
la fois une couleur qui soit à la sncf
qui soit à la fois innovante originale
mais qui s'inscrivent aussi nombreux à
l'époque des fauteuils un plateau une
table basse en passant par les vêtements
le musée de la ville possède une
collection de design très importante
cette exposition intègre également
quelques prêts d'oeuvres d'art notamment
une extension de césar de 1969 qui
proviennent du musée d'art contemporain
du val de marne
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous et la semaine prochaine dans un
autre l'ukraine yvelinois bonne soirée
sur tv 60 sites
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]